у нас е п р і з названими де
грибник прес-службу президента поясі та
німецькі журналісти як саму
організовано прес-конференцію
не на елінський травень піднято табличку
сухий змі я хочу на неї за харчування до
президента азап це не юний чу мало
журналістка гидко на 20 не митьку
модних ви данина з ними чон і швейцарії то
австрії нас слухати чиніть кувати човід
будуть з вибори потяг мова на сході
україни і я порошенку собі дивуючи
подальше вигулювання про конфлікт у краї
не вранці від і відповіди їй так і не
вдалося а дерма шуму і всю
прес-конференцію не на голкінський протрі
мало топчуть над головою просто клітор
порошенка слова їй не треба у
на прес-конференції буду про судно з
на 200 журналістиків тим вище будинок просто
онуками наземних видай дав йому жив та
весь заплутатися президента
такої організації і я можу обговорити і в
вдома зі своїм пара скарбу чим отруйною
конференція по телевізору на них по
100 ват і свої за харчування про вибір у
кого правосуддя в Україні та ще й
журналіст німецького видання
дирк lustig на томі мою думку українська
кулі харчування президенту ставив і
розпливчастим а я ще й булыга стрип це
не я то президент навіть професій на
видно вухо або ж вся видно
такого резонансу я в українські зміни
заході за його порошенко навик local і
коней як вони травневих видай написала
про заяву українського президента
короткі форматі ви за видами луня
на думку шо бог німецьких журналістиків
було просунути не на прес-конференції
злить акули повстання влада у кого не
журналістів із президентом у краї нини
багатий ще змінилося
реформи застрягли на місці, а скрутіть її
влада бор і тілки на словах